[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина
Слов'янськ]
Глина є повсюди. Вона жива.
Свіжа глина, яку ти викопав з кар'єру, є ніякою.
Раніше казали, що глина повинна вимерзнути.
Триста-чотириста тисяч років
вона пролежала.
Глина, коли виходить на поверхню схожа на дитину, яка тільки що народилася.
[Інна та Євген Павленки
Гончарі]
Вона відчула повітря. І тоді почали відбуватися окислюючі та відновлюючі процеси.
Глина стає кращою, коли пролежить пів року,
або добре було б, якщо рік.
У нас в Слов'янську були містотворчі
підприємства пов'язані з керамікою.
В один момент ці заводи розвалились,
але люди залишились.
Залишився в них і людський досвід.
Завдяки цьому почали утворюватися маленькі цехи: один, другий, третій, четвертий.
Це все збільшувалось і
дійшло до ось таких масштабів.
В нас було дуже багато цехів до війни.
Продукція проходить 7-8 етапів обробки.
Заливальник заливає.
Майстриня із замивки це замиває.
Хтось носик і ручку приклеює.
В цей час дівчата його оздоблюють.
Якраз глазурувальник його поглазурував.
Тут його вже в молоці викупали.
Там воно вже пройшло обробку у печі.
Кожна людина у цей процес душу вклала.
Це наші катакомби.
Ми тут працюємо з 1999 року.
[Вікторія Попова
Гончарка]
Зараз почну розмовляти суржиком.
На цьому моменті моя
державна мова закінчилася.
Тут мама працює, там тато.
В цьому приміщенні чоловік,
який вийшов тільки що.
Зараз я вам покажу,
як народжується українська калина.
Це мій творчий процес.
Ми самі це придумали.
У нас запитують на ринку,
який це розпис,
чи часом не петриківський.
Я питаюсь їх, чи вони бачили,
як він виглядає,
і відповідаю, що це не він.
Люди продовжують цікавитися
в мене, який це розпис.
Я кажу, що це поповський.
Маємо такий, який придумали Попови.
Ось погляньте.
Тут у нас гончарна кімната.
Я тут працюю,
а ось тут працює
другий гончар Вова.
[Дмитро Яровий
Гончар]
Він має більше досвіду, ніж я.
Вова робить набагато більші вироби.
Він хлопець, який має масивну статуру.
Вова колись служив у
Повітрянодесантних військах України.
Я у нього навчався.
Мої мама і тато розпочали
цей бізнес ще у 90-х роках
і робили тоді кераміку з білої глини.
Коли вже війна почалася у Слов'янську,
то все припинилося.
У багатьох людей війна
зруйнувала виробництво,
а деякі просто поїхали з міста.
Після визволення Слов'янська,
я вирішив повернутися
та допомогти своїм батькам.
Ми поспілкувалися з мамою і вона каже:
«Досить вже працювати на дядька».
В той час я працював
арт-директором у глянцевому виданні.
Ми подались на грант програми розвитку ООН
і отримали максимальну суму грошей
на розвиток підприємства.
Зараз у нас працює 12 людей.
Я двадцять років займаюся
виробництвом кераміки.
Почав цю справу у Грузії.
Потім до Москви запросили.
Там цех побудували.
[Бесік Каландадзе
Гончар]
Потім я повернувся до Грузії.
Через два роки приїхав сюди, одружився, народились діти.
Тут я вже працюю десять років.
Займаюсь гончарством.
Після того, як глина висихає,
ми відправляємо її до печі.
Вище, вище!
Підстав щось.
–Тримаєш?
–Так.
Тут зараз температура 300 градусів.
Коли охолоне, то витягнемо.
Мені було ще 19 років,
коли я почав займатися гончарством.
Цим потрібно займатися дуже багато,
щоб створити підприємство і розвивати цю справу.
В Слов'янську в нас
дуже дешеві керамічні вироби.
Дуже важко виживати,
якщо ти у день робиш 10-20 штук.
Наприклад, ось таких предметів
я можу 200 штук зробити за день.
Інакше виробництва б не існувало.
Коли фантазія буяє,
то можна щось ось таке видумати.
Наприклад, ось це навіть
не знаю, як назвати.
Це щось цікаве,
принаймні для мене.
Це наші майстрині.
Ось тут малюнки ангобом.
Це рідка глина у тюбику.
ЇЇ потрібно вичавити,
щоб намалювати такі візерунки.
Це різновид різьблення по глині,
ми його так називаємо.
Так...
Наші діди і прадіди ще з давніх-давен
робили вироби з червоної глини
і сушили їх на сонечку.
Вважалося, що це так має бути.
Якщо ви робите каву
у турочці з червоної глини,
яка не глазурована всередині,
то з кожним разом цей напій
ставатиме смачнішим.
Багато людей досі не розуміють
ідеї виробів з глини.
Мало кого цікавить, що це зроблено руками майстра,
що це — так званий hand made.
До мене друг приїжджає з Італії
і запитує скільки воно коштує.
І я відповідаю, що 100₴, наприклад.
Він каже, що я не ціную свою працю.
Наводить приклад,
що в Італії такі вироби коштують 50€.
Оскільки в нас тут величезний алабай
без будь-яких документів,
то про виїзд
навіть ніхто й не думав.
Ось. Так що ми пересиділи це все.
Пересиділи так, що ми
навіть з ополченцями сварились.
Усе здавалося як якесь шоу.
Та не може такого бути!
Ми не могли повірити. Які хлопці?
Потім ми вже зрозуміли,
бо тут усе життя працюємо.
Є такі люди, які постійно ходили і дивились,
де погано висять дроти,
де можна щось зрізати,
у кого можна щось вкрасти.
А тоді їх поставили на місце, дали в руки автомати
і вони відчули себе царями у цьому місті.
Це допомогло людям
змінити свої пріоритети.
Дехто вважає, жили в Україні, а потім
виявилось, що не в ній, як моя мама каже.
Це хлопцям з мого 90-го батальйону.
То ті, що аеропорт захищали. Їх ще кіборгами називають.
Просили, щоб я зробив їм.
Ось це ми робили хлопцям шеврон «Кіборги» і приклеювали на чашки.
Після війни в нас побільшало
друзів, а саме військових.
Багато з них родом з Житомира.
Вони вже майже стали
нашою сім'єю за чотири роки.
Хлопці сюди приїжджають в гості
і нас кличуть до себе.
Здається, що ця рідина схожа на нутеллу.
Залишимо на декілька хвилин,
а потім подивимося на результат.
Цей процес називається «лиття».
Воно ще виглядає сиреньким.
Я боюсь розірвати.
Бачите?
Ми потримали небагато часу,
тому стінка не зовсім товста.
Це міг бути чайничок.
Як ви можете побачити, це гончарний виріб.
Ми його задули звичайним кефіром,
який можна пити і їсти.
Справжній натуральний продукт.
Це не з фарби і не з лаку.
Потім ми його шліфуємо
і наносимо бджолиний віск.
Тут немає нічого складного.
Ми працюємо над тим,
щоб продавати свої вироби у Європі.
Це не лише змінить місто,
а й змінить Україну.
Конкуренція — це життя.
Не сидиш з вудочкою біля ставка,
звісивши ноги, а постійно працюєш.
Бо той хто працює,
той розвивається.
В Слов'янську дуже сильна конкуренція,
бо в нас місто керамістів.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
KASAЇ, OVERKO, Heinali]
[Субтитрувальниця
Ярина Фаюра]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]